kind of interesting the gay community
that we went through so much profiling
in our history and yet we are the first
profiler peers my initial reaction when
I found out I was HIV positive was that
I was never ever going to have sex again
I was never going to be in a
relationship again it just was basically
over and at last if we're quite a while
I didn't know what to do where to turn I
didn't think I was ever going to be
worth dating after being hiv-positive it
happened but you know I didn't go
through the stress or the angst that
many people experience that I've many of
my friends that have become positive
have experienced I attended my first
leather event and I found out that the
leather community is very open in a
cepting of people people that are
positive I got a lot of really rude
nasty messages online from people with
no profile pictures no way to identify
who they were and just you know saying
that you know I'm giving people AIDS on
purpose or that I am infecting people um
that I'm going to die that I deserved it
because I'm sexually free or actually
liberated so I deserve it that I'm a
[ __ ] yeah on some of these dating sites
they use a phrase when they're looking
for certain person you'll say you have
you must be clean so I'm being profound
as being a dirty person because I'm HIV
positive which is like farthest from the
truth so there's a stigma there for sure
it actually really sucks
for instance on Grindr I've been blocked
when I've been like open and honest they
solely look at your diagnosis categorize
you like most of us do in America put
you in a box
and then kind of shove you off to the
side I was able to have some
relationships as far as um being
physical with guys again but the
boyfriend thing never happened I have
been single since the 80s to may be HIV
positive is I don't really notice it you
know it's
it's just something that I you know it's
part of me but I don't think about it I
take a pill at night and besides going
to a doctor every three months into my
blood work he said it's really a
non-issue for me it doesn't affect my
life to those of you who won't open up
your heart and date someone who is HIV
positive you need to open a book or go
to a website just like I did with the
advent of better medications for the
last eight to ten years I've been
undetectable which means that it's
almost impossible for me to pass on the
virus so with my undetectable status and
condoms in and prep that's just a triple
layer of protection
people are definitely missing out if
they are closing themselves off from
anybody who is positive or black Asian
or feminine
you never know what a person has inside
them and how he will surprise you if you
actually give him a chance to get to
know him you were truly missing out if
you are not meeting somebody just
because of a checklist on his profile
[Music]